In a desperate and pathetic attempt to shift
the blame, Texas Republican politicians
and right wing media figures are lying to
their own residents and to their audiences
and claiming that green energy and windmills are
responsible for the tragic power outages that have
been taking place in the state of Texas in the
midst of unusually but not completely unexpected
cold temperatures there. And the reason
that they are so desperate to lie about this
is that it's not just a matter of accountability
for the fact that there are now millions without
power and without heat in Texas during some of the
coldest weather that they've seen in a long time.
But their entire political ideology is tied up
in government, doesn't really need to do stuff,
meaning infrastructure spending. Green
energy is bad. Their entire ideology
is crumbling. And so now they are telling the
lie that windmills are the reason that what's
going on in Texas is now taking place.
And these people include Republican
Governor Greg Abbott not telling the truth. It
includes Tucker Carlson. It includes many others.
The problem in Texas is not wind energy.
And we're going to go through it today.
And out of this tragedy, there is the opportunity
to inform about what happens when you ignore
climate science. So here's what's going on. More
than two million people are or have been without
power in Texas. Why? Extremely low temperatures
and snow are affecting the Texas power grid. Now,
Republicans are saying the problem is wind
power. Here is Tucker Carlson making the case.
Welcome to Tucker Carlson. So happy Monday. Well,
the green New Deal has come, believe it or not,
to the state of Texas. And we're here with
the report. How's it working out so far? Well,
the good news is all that alternative energy seems
to have had a remarkable effect on the climate as
intended. Last night, parts of Texas got to
temperatures that we see in Alaska. In fact,
they were the same as they were in Alaska.
So global warming is no longer a pressing
concern in Houston. We've solved that problem.
The bad news is they don't have electricity.
The windmills froze, so the power grid failed.
Now, there are two big lies there.
The first is that cold weather in Texas disproves
so-called global warming. This is an old one.
Climate science predicts not just warmer global
average temperatures, but localized record highs
and record lows, more erratic weather, what we
would call unseasonable temperatures high and low.
So Tucker's first point is terrible. The fact that
it's cold in Texas doesn't disprove anything. In
fact, it's predicted by climate science.
But secondly secondly, excuse me. Tucker
says the reason for the blackouts is
that the windmills froze. And this is so,
so, so not true as a reason for what happened.
And it's important to have the facts. ICE
has forced some wind turbines
to shut down. That's true.
But wind power is only between 10 and 25 percent
of the Texas energy mix at this time of year.
The majority of the outages were caused
by frozen instruments at natural gas,
coal and nuclear plants that were not prepared
for such cold weather, even though they could
have been. And again, cold weather predicted
by climate science models for decades as
meteorologists quinsy vagal pointed out on
Twitter, the power outages in Texas are in
areas predominantly powered by natural
gas. This was not caused by going green
with some of Texas energy supply. But Republicans
in Texas desperate to blame someone else,
are blaming wind power. Here is Republican Texas
Governor Greg Abbott on Fox News last night
saying what we're seeing in Texas right
now is a preview of the Green New Deal.
What good is it?
So this shows how the
green New Deal would be a deadly deal for the
United States of America. Texas is blessed with
multiple sources of energy, such as natural gas
and oil and nuclear, as well as solar and wind.
But you saw from what Troy said, and that is our
win in our solar, they got shut down and they were
collectively more than 10 percent of our power
grid. And that thrust Texas into a situation where
it was lacking power in a statewide basis. That
was power that was spread out by that organization
or organization that you were talking about.
And then here is Fox and Friends this morning.
But he said for the first time, he's seeing
a little bit of California now with what
happened with the weather and the wind turbines.
One of the things that the climate denial industry
does is to sow doubt and to claim that there
are controversies and unknowns whether or not
this is a really old playbook. It's described
in the book Merchants of Doubt. They did it with
smoking. When they couldn't do it with smoking,
they shifted to doing it with second hand smoke.
They did it with acid rain. They did it with
the pesticide DDT. They did it with the hole
in the ozone layer. They've been doing it with
various elements of climate change, create doubt
and manufacture a controversy where there isn't
one. And I saw lots of people on online saying,
I don't know. You know, there's just it's hard
to know what the truth is about what's going on
in Texas because each side has their view. We're
going to have to wait. It's going to take time
to figure out what the truth is about the role of
green energy or not in what is taking place. No.
We have the facts making it confusing is the
playbook that they use a wind is not even
close to the main issue and wind is actually
outperforming energy output expectations for
this time of year in Texas, blaming the problems
of frozen instruments at coal, natural gas and
nuclear plants on wind turbine freezing shows
two things. Number one, they're lying to you.
And number two, these are problems that have been
solved in other states. But Texas has refused to
actually deal with it. If in Texas they had
accepted climate science, they would know
No. One, we should expect more erratic weather.
And because that can mean really cold weather,
it means that we should weather proof not only
the wind turbines, but the coal plant instruments,
the gas plant instruments and the nuclear plant
instruments. Many other states have done this.
Listen, it gets cold in Wyoming and Montana.
They have wind power as well. There are known
solutions to this. We're going to look in the
next segment at a report from a decade ago
based on prior power outages in Texas,
saying here's the things you have to do
to protect yourselves from this in the future.
Extremely cold weather affects natural gas and
oil pipelines because it changes pressure. It
affects instruments at nuclear plants. This is not
a this is not new information and this is not
unique to Texas. Texas could have chosen to
weatherproof not just wind, nuclear and
nuclear, wind, nuclear and natural gas,
which are mostly their sources of energy,
but also the wind turbines. And Texas
got crushed because its operators and its
politicians chose not to be prepared for cold
weather. That's the story. Now, once people
the priority is getting people power back.
Once people have power back and are safe, who is
going to be held accountable for this? Because
there are people responsible. Let's talk a little
bit about the history of this story in Texas next.